the local real estate market is red hot
right now and the question
is how long will this upward swing
continue
i spoke with jared urane of palacios
realty to get some answers
it has been a fascinating and uh very
vibrant
housing market uh what does the summer
look like
goodness kendall uh first of all thank
you for your invitation
um we're gonna continue the hot trend in
fact it's vegas so
we just kind of have to get used to hot
for a minute uh the median sales price
right now is 375 thousand dollars for
a single family residence uh that's
actually about three percent over march
and when we take a look at that from the
2020 perspective over the last 12 months
21 uh appreciation for homeowners so
wow really really crazy and it's going
to continue for the next few months the
good news is
we have made progress on the inventory
shortage so we've got a little bit more
inventory than we did
the month before it's not much but we're
making progress it's the direction we
need to head the concern obviously
for anyone who is looking to buy a home
right now is that we are in another
bubble
with 21 uh appreciation
appreciation on the homes that's
incredible so
if what would you tell those people who
are worried they're just going to buy a
house only to see its value go down
almost
immediately that is a natural uh feeling
for many
people especially those who experienced
uh maybe some loss
in the last recession uh the difference
we live
in today is that uh the owners that own
property
well we know nationally over 60 percent
of them
have 50 percent equity or more so
there's plenty of
of safety net for them to be able to
sell in fact
almost 30 of those have absolutely no
mortgage at all we know also the buyers
that have purchased over the last 10
years
they've all been able to afford their
home
we also know that their affordability
has increased so now buyers are able to
afford a little more the appreciation
that we're seeing right now is
direct result of the inventory shortage
and so what we're seeing are these
prices that are increasing and it's
getting a little uncomfortable it's kind
of new territory
but there's nothing wrong with it for
those who are looking to sell and buy
move out of their current home into a
new home uh
with everything being snapped up so
quickly how can they make sure
that they do it all in one move as
opposed to selling their home moving out
staying somewhere temporarily and then
moving into their new home permanently
that is a that is a special uh technique
and one that really takes some
expertise to negotiate and prepare for
we have established over 10
different solutions for different
scenarios because we know everybody's
got a different situation
i'll give you an example of one uh we
went ahead and took a listing
and we put it on coming soon we didn't
even put it on the market yet and by the
time it actually hit the market we had
multiple offers already and we made it
made it clear to those buyers look our
buyer's gonna our seller is gonna need
some time after close
two weeks minimum and so we had these
offers already in hand
with those terms available to the buyer
and the moment we had those in hand we
went out shopping and within two weeks
of putting it on the market
we were able to secure their purchase
and so what we did there is we were able
to take a listing and get that
by that seller into the next property
one move one time
within 45 days jared great insight
really appreciate your time today thanks
for joining us
appreciate it kendall thank you so much
you can give palacios
realty a call at that phone number
702-333-6666 what a cool phone number
check out their special mention channel
8 for a free one-year home
warranty with a home purchase we'll be
right back